so now I want to think about this whole
second of being zero and first through
being equal zero at the same time okay
because there's another common example
which you don't have to draw because I
mean you know very well but I'm going to
get you to UM write x cubed and we're
gonna differentiate a couple times and
see what happens so here's what makes
cubed Y please excuse
okay so first derivative 3x square right
second derivative 6x right okay so again
at the origin you've got first root of 0
second derivative 0 that's quite
different to the example we just looked
at right what kind of point is this is
it a turning point it's not a turning
point because it doesn't go up and then
go down or vice versa it just goes up
and then goes on this is that we
anti-gravity Napa we're thinking about
before right so not at any point is it a
stationary what's the definition for a
station
three to zero or you could say the
tangent at that point should be
horizontal and that checks out right so
it is a stationary point okay
how else can we describe this we just
worked out the second derivative right
what kind of point is this yeah yeah
good we looked at this right there's a
change in concavity it's concave down
for these values right
and then it's concave up for these
values okay so it is also a point of
inflection okay this is important okay
so I'm going to put it in another color
when you have these two coexisting at
the same time namely a stationary point
and important inflection when you look
at it what kind of feature is it well
it's a horizontal point of an infection
right because the points of inflection
we looked at before like X cubed plus X
looks kind of like this right you can
still see the concave down part and the
concave up part but at that point there
it's not horizontal right but this one
is so you remember we said stationary
points right they might be turning point
or they might not be if they're not
turning points there it is horizontal
points of inflection
okay so first three related 0 cos
horizontal second derivative is zero
because you have the change in concavity
okay